Allemagne depuis le 1er mai je pense que
vous l'avez suivi vous avez accès pour
49 euros par mois à tous les trains en
illimité tous les trains de région hors
TGV et pour le reste tous les trains
est-ce que c'est le genre de mesure vous
comptez le mettre en place en France oui
j'y suis favorable et j'ai demandé au
ministre des Transports de lancer avec
toutes les régions qui sont prêtes à le
faire le même dispositif la réalité est
chez nous c'est que c'est les régions
qui ont la tarification de leurs billets
qui font leur billet toutes les régions
qui sont prêtes à le faire avec l'État
banco et un tour de table avec les
régions et si c'est le cas on aura un
service similaire exactement France dans
les prochains mois comme la première
ministre porte cette idée